bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
volleyball le club de plaisir du poids
facilement dominé rennes dans sa salle à
l'occasion de la 10e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 le score 3
sets à 1 plus d'informations dans ce
magazine is porte killian faucheux est à
14 ans l'un des meilleurs joueurs
français de football sur console a
notamment remporté la paris games week
et l'adolescent fait partie de l'une des
meilleures équipes du monde son portrait
dans quelques instants
foot us c'est la reprise de ce week-end
championnat de deuxième division les
templiers d'elancourt seront les vikings
de villeneuve d'ascq nous ferons le
point sur la préparation des
footballeurs avant cette nouvelle saison
mais avant de développer ces titres un
point sur les matchs europe de reporter
de ce week-end à cause de la neige du
froid et du verglas en rugby chez le
comité des yvelines a décidé vendredi
dernier de reporter à une date
ultérieure tous les matches en dessous
de la fédérale 3 suite aux intempéries
les principaux rendez-vous concernés
dans les yvelines était versailles
menthe et le sky rugby contre noisy le
grand
des matches de football ont également
été reportés en coupe d i mean c'est le
cas de la rencontre limay contre
l'équipe 2 de trappes pour l'instant les
ligues n'ont pas encore communiqué les
dates pour jouer ces matches on passe
maintenant à notre rubrique résultats
pas de souci pour jouer à ce week end
match de volley ball dans les yvelines
promu cette saison en nationale 3 le
club de plaisir vite preuve a facilement
dominé dans son gymnase l'équipe de
rennes 35
le score 3 7 1 cette victoire permet au
club de grimper à la 4e place du
classement
nicolas landry a pour les images
l'équipe senior de plaisir villepreux
débute l'année par une victoire les
bleus se sont imposés ce dimanche 15
janvier à domicile contre le club de
rennes à l'occasion de la 10e journée de
nationale 3 après avoir remporté les
deux premiers sets 25 17 et 25 21 les
plaisirs ont perdu le troisième set de
justesse 25 à 23 avant de conclure le
match 25 à 19
score final 3 7 1 on a pris le match
dans nos mains tous les secteurs
offensive et défensive et ils ont
fonctionné il y avait une baisse de
rythme sur certaines phases de jeu
notamment dans le troisième set qu'on
n'a pas su à un moment donné rebondir
pour pouvoir rentrer dans les premières
phases du jeu et le quatrième set c'est
surtout le mental pour nous c'est un
match important c'était bien de se
remettre dedans ça nous va nous redonner
un peu de confiance
suffisamment pour que l'on puisse aller
chercher le prochain match
voilà et pas trop pour que en même temps
on est à se remettre en question parce
qu'il y avait des choses à revoir quand
même au classement plaisir villepreux
promu cette saison en nationale 3
reprend la 4e place du classement
l'objectif annoncé en début de saison
avec un bilan de six victoires et quatre
défaites depuis le début de la saison
est pour l'instant pas question pour le
club de parler de montée avec cinq
points de retard sur les premières
places
sylviane pourquoi pas mais je pense que
les première et deuxième est qu'ils ont
pris énormément de poids
l'objectif de cette année c'était
d'abord le maintien pour construire un
et prochain pour pouvoir après avoir
l'objectif
prochain match pour l'équipe ce dimanche
22 janvier contre en gerbes l'ont
toujours à domicile on va maintenant
sortir la grand voile dans cette
émission pour parler du vendée globe
après plus de soixante dix jours de
course no2 illinois louis burton
originaire de rambouillet éric bellion
qui a grandi à versailles sont toujours
en lice pour terminer ce tour du monde
en solitaire
ils sont à plus de 3000 milles nautiques
des leader armel le cléac'h et alex
thomson mais les navigateurs des
yvelines sont toujours ancrés à la 7e à
la 9e place et les sportifs sont en
train de remonter vers la france au
large du brésil
on regarde une séquence enregistrée par
éric bellion ce week-end j'ai eu un
petit coup de fatigue après le cap horn
savez quand vous êtes tellement tendue
vers un objectif comme ça a été mon cas
avec le cap horn
j'en rêvais en navigation j'étais
vraiment tendu quand je vous disais
quand est ce que j'allais passer le cap
horn
enfin vraiment c'était quelque chose que
je visais et puis une fois passé ben bon
la tension est tombée et
la fatigue est arrivé je me repose je
m'occupe du bateau très bien et puis
maintenant c'est en route on remonte au
football ont joué ce week-end la coupe
des yvelines l'équipe senior de
guyancourt qui évolue en excellence est
allé s'imposer sous la neige sur le
terrain de villes pro au troisième tour
de la compétition légumes en cours tant
dominé leurs adversaires 4 à 2 avec
notamment ce but de l'extérieur de la
surface de réparation
comme on peut le voir à l'écran notre
journaliste nicolas d'andré a recueilli
la réaction du coach de l'ulg on fait
une bonne première mi temps avec eux les
consignes ont été bien respectées on a
joué vers l'avant un gros pressing en
début de match donc on a marqué au bout
d'une minute après on a mieux on a mis
le deuxième but au bout de 7 minutes
donc bonne entame de match
après on a un petit peu tomber dans la
facilité donc ce qui a rendu le match un
peu plus compliqué pour nous sur la
deuxième mi temps mais dans l'ensemble
on l'a bien maîtrisé
on va parler de golf à présent la
nouvelle est tombée le lundi 9 janvier
le groupe chinois hachana va sponsoriser
l'open de france ce partenariat d'une
durée de cinq ans va permettre au
tournoi implantée à vue en cours
d'augmenter ses taux de sa dotation par
trois pour arriver à 6,3 millions
d'euros et d'intégrer le rolex séries le
gratin du golf mondial en termes de
tournoi conséquence directe des stars de
la discipline devrait débarquer le 29
juin prochain sur les greens de saint
quentin en yvelines pour les accueillir
et recevoir le public des modifications
sur l'organisation sont envisagées on
écoute le directeur du golf national à
paul hermitage
on parle d'une feuille blanche
concernant par exemple quelques aspects
du village des choses comme ça la
circulation du public
ils ont d'autres idées
pour l'utilisation de l'espace dans
lequel on se trouve qui est notre
accueil pro shop club house donc c'est
super intéressante parce que on sent que
qu'il y aura des changements changement
ça peut faire peur mais moi je pense que
ce sera des changements intéressants
pour l'événement c'est une discipline
qui commence à percer le hisse porte le
sport électronique sur consoles en
france des milliers de joueurs
participent à des tournois et rire et
récolte des gains considérables
le psg ou encore nantes ont créé leur
propre équipe dans les yvelines
un nom circule avec insistance celui de
killian faucheuse à 14 ans il est
considéré comme l'un des meilleurs jours
en france
nous l'avons rencontré à chez lui à
houilles le montage est signée romain
respini qu'il y à de faux cheveux 14 ans
n'est pas un adolescent comme les autres
ce collégien de 3e est actuellement
considéré comme le futur prodige dhuys
portes en france du sport via les jeux
vidéo sa spécialité le football jeune
marque des buts avec sa touche carré
déplace ses joueurs avec son joli stick
depuis ses 6 ans quand j'étais petit mon
père un petit peu au jeu vidéo avant
j'étais justement forme qui perdait
souvent et après je me sens très de
s'entraîner entraîné je joue un peu en
ligne et du coup après l' envie de jouer
aux jeux vidéo show jeu de foot
après avoir emporté des centaines de
matchs en ligne qu'ils viennent alias
kills ou s'est fait un nom plutôt un
pseudo dans le milieu en 2015 il a
intégré la neo x porte ce 95 une équipe
d'une quinzaine d'adeptes composé selon
les spécialistes des meilleurs joueurs
du monde sur les jeux de football fifa
et pes 6 mai pour beaucoup de choses
pour basse et l'esprit d'équipé
il ya les tournois qui se font aussi en
équipe il ya toujours du président où
n'importe qui peut te dépanner pour
quelque chose s'est amené en tournoi on
part en plus à plusieurs c'est toujours
mieux partir tout seul à cinq heures de
route
une alchimie qui fonctionne qui viennent
a remporté des dizaines de tournois dont
celui de la paris games week
des performances qui lui ont permis
d'empocher près de 1500 euros cette
année
mais pour continuer à progresser le
sportif virtuel s'entraînent une heure
tous les jours une passion encouragé par
sa mère sous certaines conditions
je pousse à continuer
mais comme tous les parents à condition
que qu'il soit sérieux au niveau de ces
notes et de ses études un entraînement
nécessaires pour accomplir son plus
grand rêve devenir le meilleur joueur du
monde du x porte dans les prochaines
années
on passe maintenant notre rubrique
agenda
on ouvre une page boxe dans ce set
sports ce sera peut-être le combat le
plus important de sa vie de sportif
marvin petit à 25 ans double champion de
france va affronter ce samedi au palais
des sports marcel cerdan de levallois
perret l'espagnol de 26 ans aurait robes
et santana deux fois champion du monde
junior wbc en jeu le titre de champion
de france de l'union européenne des
poids légers
nous avons pu rencontrer à l'élan
courtois juste avant son combat
si avec marvin petit kit originaire d'el
en cours il est en train de préparer en
ce moment son combat pour le titre de la
ceinture européenne des poids légers
il va affronter un espagnol santana à
levallois dans quelques jours alors
marvin comment vous sentez vous à
l'approché ce combat là personnellement
je suis je me sens je me sens bien c'est
on va dire c'est même la première fois
je me sens aussi bien que ça j'ai fait
une bonne bonne préparation avec bob
site a donc là je pense que ce combat je
vais j'ai ramené ses ceintures et des
gens plus à la base c'est chez nous le
combat vers la ceinture noire est en
france donc
santana c'est un gros morceau il a
remporté 14 victoires en 14 combats
disputés
vous avez une seule défaite dans votre
carrière en pro voilà que le match
s'annonce équilibré en tout cas explosif
oui ça va être déjà ce jeu suit aucun
aucun adversaire et ça va être un gros
combat
c'est un très très bon boxeur sa
styliste donc je pense que moi voilà je
vais faire mon taf que comme un conte a
établi avec tanguy moi dans ma tête je
suis prêt maintenant j'ai
je suis pressé d'être au rendez vous le
21 et comment avez-vous axé votre
préparation ça a été plus dur peut-être
que d'habitude pour ce combat qui sera
peut-être le combat de votre vie on peut
le dire oui on va dire c'est le combat
qui va m'apporter beaucoup dans ma
carrière parce que la faux pas je laisse
passer cette ceinture ces rediffusions
direction qu'elle n'allait plus déjà et
c'est une ceinture de l'union européenne
que je peux pas lui donner c'est pas
possible j'ai très très belle non je
pourrai pas lui donner même qu'il est
invaincu je vais lui mettre une défaite
face à tout le monde
tout le monde passe par là et moi je me
rappelle contre yvan mendy j'avais
quatorze combats 14 victoires et voilà
c'est pas pour ça qu'il m'a pas battu
il y à la caméra juste devant vous
justement vous ici est-ce que vous
pouvez adresser un message à votre
adversaire santana si nous regarde en ce
moment sur tv fil 78 mais j'espère que
des plats préparés santana parce que
j'étais garantie je tire vraiment
vraiment du mal et il y aura in hôpital
pas très loin avec beaucoup de
pansements ci s'est assuré turix le
message est passé
marvin le jeu et rappelle le combat est
programmée ce samedi 21 janvier à
levallois
on termine par du football américain les
templiers d'elancourt qui seront cette
année en deuxième division après avoir
été rétrogradé la saison dernière
joueront leur premier match ce samedi à
20 heures au complexe sportif europe
nous avons pris la température à
quelques jours de ce rendez vous nicolas
landry a pour les images c'est la
reprise pour les templiers d'elancourt
l'équipe senior rétrogradé la saison
dernière en deuxième division reprend le
championnat ce samedi 21 janvier à 20
heures à domicile contre les vikings de
villeneuve d'ascq pour être prêt pour ce
rendez vous les élans courtois se
prépare physiquement et tactiquement
depuis septembre ça s'est bien passé la
préparation on a eu quelques blessés au
début de l'année
pas mal de tendinites et c'est donc il
ya pas mal de joueurs qui ont été
impulsés entraîné un pompier
hormis en remuant on a réussi quand même
installé le
nouveau système tout se passe bien
normalement se battrait tous les matches
de pré saison ont été remportés ils ont
tous réussi à assimiler le système donc
on a bon espoir de faire un bon premier
match du côté des joueurs étrangers les
templiers ont décidé de renouveler leur
confiance à l'américain jesse riddick
déjà présent la saison dernière et
dirigeants ont également décidé de
recruter ben cooper un joueur de 2 m
originaire de l'ohio pour muscler leur
ligne offensive
ma qualité en football sont de m'adapter
pendant les situations de match je
promets que je suis un vrai technicien
mon coach à l'université m'a d'ailleurs
beaucoup appris deux techniques
il m'a également appris à devenir un
travailleur acharné ils ont commencé à
jouer quand il avait s'attend donc
forcément ça une plus grosse culture du
football ils sont nés là dedans et son
grandi là dedans dont ils peuvent
transmettre ce que c'est de performer au
plus haut niveau et et qu'est ce qu'il
faut pour gagner dans ce sport avant ce
premier match les dirigeants des temples
y ont également fixé les objectifs les
joueurs doivent aller en playoffs et si
possible remontée dès cette saison en
première division
on souhaite évidemment bonne chance aux
templiers d'elancourt pour ce premier
match de la saison
c'est la fin sur 7,8 sport merci l'avoir
suivi très belle soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]